welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham and there are truly not
enough R-rated expletives for excitement
that Wolverine and Deadpool are finally
getting a movie together the first one
didn't count and even though fox really
botched Logan and Wade's initial
Bromance both Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman have kept their love aflame for
each other and these characters for 13
years by the time Deadpool 3 actually
premieres in 2024 their superhero
Frenemy ship will be a whole entire 10th
grader but Deadpool and Wolverine's
friendship and sometimes fauxhip spans
far beyond the last decade and a half of
bad character design and fourth wall
breaking digs I'm gonna break down not
only their cinematic history within the
fox verse but some of their coolest
fights from the comics as well and
because we all know how much Kevin feige
loves to use the comics as a road map
for future films and TV series I also
have a few predictions about how some of
these story lines might end up in the
next phase of the MCU all the way back
in 2009 beautiful monstrosity that his
X-Men Origins Wolverine Grace to Silver
Screen and look I was obsessed with that
movie when it first came out I saw it in
theaters at the mall by my high school
three times not only did it have Hugh
Jackman Ryan Reynolds and Liev Schreiber
it also had will I am from the Black
Eyed Peas for some reason he has not
acted in a single live-action film as a
fictional character since it's a
masterpiece but it has its flaws the
most eagerius being the [ __ ] version
of Wade Wilson they've forced us to sit
with until literally 2016. I don't need
a Deadpool spleen to a bunch of Marvel
freaks why everything about this variant
blue dick for Skittles but this muted
nerfed version of The Merc with a mouth
just ain't it bro Ryan Reynolds spent
the next several years perfecting his
ideal version of Deadpool Rowdy horny
violent and R-rated and crushed it with
his 2016 reboot of the character in his
first cinematic wall break Deadpool
tells us that he had to fondle
Wolverines smooth criminals just to get
his own movie later on we even see a
tiny plastic action figure of his shitty
character design from 2009 in his
apartment and when Wade finally reveals
his jacked up face to Vanessa at the end
he uses Hugh Jackman's photo from people
Magazine's sexiest man alive magazine
cover from 2008 to soften the blow
2018's dead thankful too however is
where Reynolds really changed the
timeline and continuity of these two
characters after making several
references to his buddy Wolverine
including a dead Logan music box
a wolverine superhero flake cereal that
he signs from Ryan Reynolds a cartoon
crayon drawn picture of Wolverine
labeled prisoner 24601 which is a
reference to Jackson's role in Les Mis
and Wolverine's death song from the
final scene of Logan Deadpool uses
Cable's repaired time travel device to
visit the year 2009 after blowing his
own brains out thereby cleaning up the
timeline he makes Wolverine promise him
that even if he someday decides to hang
up the claws he'll come back for a movie
cut to the Deadpool 3 teaser where ryry
asks you to saddle back up and now we're
on a precipice of seeing the fan
favorite pairing share a feature the
internet is a buzz with joy but why is
that the case is this a matter of fans
wanting to see the Bromance of these two
actors once again on screen or is the
comic Duo truly iconic Deadpool and
Logan had their comic book meet up back
in 1994 within the pages of Wolverine
number 88. this issue saw them face off
as foes with Deadpool hunting down
Garrison Kane AKA Weapon X for dating
his ex Vanessa and Wolverine
intercepting him as expected the gruff
Wolverine was not a fan of Deadpool's
incessant blabbering Deadpool actually
gets the upper hand on wolvey during
their first round leaving him for dead
without realizing that Wolverine can
regenerate interestingly according to
screenwriter Rhett Reese Garrison Kane
was originally in the first draft of
2016's Deadpool but was Consolidated
with other antagonists into Ajax data
budget constraints I'm wondering if it's
possible that Deadpool 3 will make
another attempt at Weapon X as a nod to
this little Miku Deadpool and Logan's
next meet and greet happened in the 1995
Wolverine annual and Logan ends up
reluctantly having to rescue Wade from a
nameless lab of evil scientists who are
experimenting on and playing Tic-Tac-Toe
with Deadpool's body during their escape
Deadpool slips away and Wolverine admits
that while he hates how annoying
Deadpool is he's not a total monster
while these brief interactions give us a
small appetizer of Deadpool and
Wolverines back and forth it's not until
97's Deadpool number 27 that we get to
see the real Chemistry Between the pair
began to form on orders of his therapist
Deadpool picks a meaningless fight with
Wolverine because ultimately they can
dish out Maximum Carnage on each other
without doing permanent harm like in
Deadpool repeatedly insults and goads
Wolverine into a rage who's just trying
to settle in old debt Wolverine
eventually tears Wade to shreds but
Deadpool gets his mental breakthrough
out of it so who's the real winner here
and this here is the core of what makes
this pair work so well they're the Itchy
and Scratchy of Marvel Comics they can
take violence to the extreme thanks to
their nigh immortality and their Dynamic
plays into their conflicting
personalities one of my favorite
Deadpool and Wolverine moments that I'd
like to see in flu instead pool 3 is
from the deep end Arc in the 2006
Wolverine Origins run in this story
Deadpool is hired out to kill Wolverine
so he decides to go full Looney Tunes on
his ass once Wade has Wolverine captured
they have a heart to heart and Wade
points out the hypocrisy he sees in the
X-Men although he and Logan are so
similar in their bloody past somehow
Wolverine is a popular X-Man and he's
stuck as a mercenary even though Logan
points out that Deadpool isn't a mutant
and thus can't be an X-Man Deadpool
still hammers home that he's unwanted
this is part of the recurring gag that
Deadpool desperately wants to be a
member of the X-Men and we can see that
it's stem is partially from a place of
jealousy and respect for his rival
Wolverine Wolverine annual 99 actually
ends with one of the best examples of
their Frenemy [ __ ] after wolverine
attacks Deadpool's revenge for punching
Kitty Pride back in 1997 the two head
out for a beer as buddies and look I'm
not saying that if your friend punches a
woman you should buy him a brewski but
in the world of superheroes these two
are well known for their hot and cold
breakups and makeups after Deadpool does
end up scamming in official X-Men
membership for himself he and wolfy do
have a number of team-ups as a part of
Wolverine's Black Ops X-Force Wayne
surprisingly ended up being a voice of
reason and Consciousness after X-Force
member Phantom X kills the child
Reincarnation of Apocalypse Deadpool
calls a meeting to discuss the team's
ethics and willingness to kill children
Wolverine ends up clashing with Deadpool
telling him that they did what needed to
be done for the greater good and accuses
dp's morality as disingenuous he's here
for the money except he's not it's
revealed that Deadpool never cashed a
single check during his year on the
X-Force and this moment reveals that
Deadpool's quest to be a hero is genuine
you even if Logan can't see past his
dickish Persona this reveal of moral
positions is actually super interesting
and I'm hoping we get to see a similar
tension in the next film another
storyline that I think we could see in
Deadpool 3 is from 2014's Deadpool
number 27. Deadpool 1 was a love story
Deadpool 2 was a story about family so
my theory is that Deadpool 3 will
feature a marriage story between Wade
and the resurrected Vanessa although the
wedding of Deadpool and operation
ballerina drop shows Wade marrying
another bride the demon ruler of the
monster Metropolis Shukla Wolverine does
show up to both the wedding and the
bachelor party of Wade Wilson Deadpool
actually asks wolvey to officiate his
nuptials but grumpy Logan obviously
declines he and Captain America do
however show up to the merc's party for
his last night as a single man hoping to
settle down the riffraff I predict that
something similar will happen in the
third installment of Deadpool it's the
most important day of his life why
wouldn't he want his bestest buddy and
longest running equally matched foe to
be there finally let's talk about the
internet's vote on the most likely
scenario for Wolverine's potential
integration into the MCA you I've seen
tons of people theorizing that Wolverine
and Deadpool will show up in secret Wars
on Battle World a patchwork world ruled
by Dr Doom made from remnants of
destroyed realities after the
multiverses collapse due to incursions I
definitely agree that this theory is
entirely possible especially with all of
the other hints throughout the first
portion of the Multiverse Saga that
incursions are and will continue to be a
major threat going forward there's no
question that Wolverine and Deadpool
would be top contenders for Secret Wars
especially because both were such major
players in both 2015 Secret Wars and
Deadpool's secret secret Wars a 2016
comic that tells us that DP was actually
involved in the first Secret Wars that
took place in the 1980s before his 1991
publication debut unfortunately he had
wasp hooked up and she was so mortified
that she made everyone forget that Wade
was a part of it while I don't think
that Deadpool is going to steal Paul
Rudd's girl I do think that we could see
both appear in an alternate universe
together in the upcoming 2025 film their
participation would be the coolest way
to end the Multiverse Saga especially if
we get to see one of the arcs from
secret secret Wars come to fruition
Deadpool fighting King it would make
perfect sense to finally Usher Wolverine
and the other X-Men into the MCU now
that other mutants like Kamala Khan have
made their appearance and I really hope
that this fan theory is true those are
just a handful of my all-time favorite
Deadpool and Wolverine scenes from the
comics but I want to know what you guys
think in the comments what stories are
your top contenders to influence the
plot of Deadpool 3. follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you